the story in the story of Adam and Eve
is a meta story and it's a meta story
for two reasons one is it's about how
stories transform because Adam and Eve
are in this unconscious paradise and
then it collapses and that happens to
every potential story right
that's Nietzsche's realization said look
imagine that you live within a belief
system and then something arises to
challenge the belief system not only
does the belief system collapse but
something worse happens your belief in
belief systems collapses and that's the
road tonight now it doesn't have to
because you can jump from one belief
system to another but sometimes that
doesn't work is that you do a meta
critique and you say oh I was living in
this protective structure and it turned
out to be flawed okay one alternative is
jumped to another protective structure
fine another alternative is protective
structures themselves are not to be
trusted
bang you're in chaos how the hell are
you going to get out of that that's the
pathway to nihilism well you can you can
you can work your way through that
that's difficult or you can do what Jung
would regard as a soil damaging move and
you can sacrifice your new knowledge
Andrey identify with something rigid and
restricted which is what I would say is
happening to some degree with the people
in you or Europe who are turning to a
regressive nationalism as an alternative
to to the current state of chaos it's
like I know that people need to identify
with local groups I understand that but
that they risk the danger of making the
state the ultimate God and that's order
but that's not a good replacement for
chaos it's just another kind of
catastrophe right
too much order too much chaos both
catastrophes you want to stand in the
middle somehow and mediate between the
two and that's where you have your real
strength because then it isn't that
you've discovered a safe place
because even the bloody right-wingers
are after a safe place right they just
want it to be the state yeah exactly
well there's no safe places and the next
issue is do you really want a safe place
is that what you want you want to be so
weak that you want to be protected from
threat what the hell kind of life is
that you're a paralyzed rabbit in a hole
that's no life for a human being
you should be confronting danger and the
unknown and malevolence because and the
reason for that too is this is the weird
paradox this is and I believe this is
the paradox first of all that was
discovered in part by a Buddha but also
laid forth very clearly in Christianity
which is that the solution to the
problem of tragedy and malevolence is
the willingness to face them now who the
hell would ever guess that it's
completely paradoxical it's a completely
paradoxical suggestion is that well why
does it work well because the more you
confront the two of them the more you
grow and maybe you can grow so that
you're actually larger than the chaos
and malevolence itself and you think
well what's the evidence for that and
that's easy that's what people do that
is how we learn like every time you
expose your child to something new a
playground
what are they exposed to chaos and
malevolence now there's more to it than
that oh obviously because kids play and
they you know they promote each other
and they form friendships and all of
that but in the playground itself there
is the complexity of the social
structure and the malevolence of the
bully it's right there and the you throw
your kid in there and you say adapt and
they do okay so they can do it at a
small scale it's not trivial the
playground is a complicated place the
kid can adapt well how much can you
scale that up can you scale that up too
from the chaos and order and malevolence
of the playground to chaos and order and
malevolence itself well that's the
question
well I don't think there's any reason to
answer that in the negative so because
we don't know the full extent of a human
being and it is the problem that's
worked out so in the Buddhist story for
example what happens after so buddha's
world collapses in the same way that
Adam and Eve's world collapses it's a
consequence of repetitive exposure to
mortality and death what happens to
Buddhas he realizes that the little
protected City that his father made for
him the walled garden it's exactly the
same motif that's in this Adam and Eve
story is is it's it's what it's fatally
flawed that kind of protection cannot
exist and he
he discovers that in pieces right which
is exactly what happens to children is
that they go out they discover a limit
they run back and the parents can help
them with the limit they run out they
discover limit they run back but some at
some point they run out they discover a
limit they run back and the parents have
nothing to say to them because they've
hit the same limit that the parents hit
just like what are you going to do with
your life how are you going to how are
you going to operate in this archetypal
universe while your parents can only say
well they can say you identify with the
proper archetypal figures they do that
they at least act that out for you but
at some point it's a problem that they
cannot solve for you without making you
weaker that's the thing you know so it's
an interesting thing that I've learned
in therapy because one of the things you
have to learn as a therapist is how do
you not take your clients problems home
with you it's a very common existential
problem that beginning therapists face
because they're afraid it's like while
you're dealing with people all the time
you have serious problems sometimes it's
mental illness although less frequently
than you think and sometimes it's just
that they're having a good catastrophe
right there their parents have cancer or
something like that or their father has
Alzheimer's and they're unemployed if
they have a drug problem or they have a
schizophrenic son or like these aren't
mental illness problems right those are
just catastrophes and so people are
discussing those with you all the time
how do you avoid being crushed by that
or avoid taking it home and the answer
that is you don't steal the problem
that's the answer it's like you have
some problems if you come and talk to me
I'll help you figure out how to solve
them I will not tell you how to solve I
won't steal your problems because what
we're trying to do in therapy is number
one solve your problem number two turn
you into a great solver of problems and
the second one is way more important
than the first one and so you never
solve someone's problem by removing from
them the opportunity to solve their
problem that's theft
that's the eatable situation that's the
eatable situation that's the
overprotective mother now father can
play that rule too we're talking about
archetypal representations it's like
I'll protect you at the cost of your
ability to protect yourself No
wrong that's that's a sin that's a good
way of thinking about that is not what
you do with people not with your
children not with your partner not with
yourself you don't do that that destroys
people's adaptive competence and it and
it disarms them in the face of chaos and
malevolence and that's a terrible unisen
someone oh darn armed in a world like
that it's a terrible thing to do so and
if people aren't strong enough to manage
it then they get resentful and then you
know you get the downhill spiral that
goes along with that okay so the meta
story is partly you're in a mat you're
you have a map but it's insufficient and
things will come up to disrupt it and
sometimes the disruption is catastrophic
everything falls apart that's what
happens to the Buddha and that's what
happens to Adam and Eve and the rest of
the biblical stories are actually an
attempt to put that back together now
that's being assembled as I said it's
been assembled over centuries right okay
we've got the problem the problem is the
apocalypse the ever-present reality of
the apocalyptic fall that's the problem
and so you could say well what is that
it's the insufficiency of all potential
conceptual schemes right your conceptual
schemes are insufficient to deal with
the complexity of the world it's a
permanent problem so what do you do you
stop relying on your conceptual schemes
that's part of the answer you start
relying on your instead on your ability
to actively generate conceptual schemes
in the face of chaos and malevolence and
so that makes you someone that
identifies with your creative capacity
your creative courageous capacity for
articulation and action in the face of
the unknown rather than some formulaic
approach to the territory and that it
not and that the idea is that that
elevates your character to the point
where you can withstand tragedy and
malevolence without becoming corrupt and
that provides a permanent solution to
the problem well then you might say
cynically what's your evidence that
that's a permanent solution an answer
that is while the evidence isn't all in
yet first of all because people only
live that way partially and so we
haven't put the hypothesis to the
test and second we don't know what our
limitations are we have no idea what our
limitations are and they're they're both
greater and lesser than we imagined
because you you know you have to ask
yourself like if people stop adding
voluntarily to the misery of the world
and devoted themselves to setting things
straight setting themselves straight and
setting the things around them straight
what would happen an answer to that is
well there'd be a hell of a lot less
unnecessary misery in the world so that
might not be a bad place to start but
apart from that there's very little that
we can say could we overcome the
catastrophe of mortality why not
you think that's beyond our capacity
could we make the world a place where no
one was suffering any more than
necessary and still allow the world to
exist well possibly because we don't
know the limitations of our capacity
we're only running at 40% if that I
would say we don't make full use of all
the people that are in the world we
don't have our situations set up so that
the gifts that they could offer to
everyone are fully realized we haven't
set the systems up for that yet so we
waste people like mad and then we waste
ourselves like mad